cuál es la probabilidad de sacar
exactamente 2 águilas al hacer tres
volados distintos recuerden en mexico
decimos águila o sol pero en muchas
otras partes del mundo se dice cara o
cruz son la misma cosa águila vamos a
decir que es cara y sol vamos a decir
que es cruz lo que pasa es que en méxico
las monedas tienen un águila de un lado
y un calendario azteca que tiene un sol
en el otro así que por eso nosotros
decimos águila o sol pero es lo mismo lo
único que pasa es que si uso cara o cruz
la anotación se me va a volver muy
complicada pero bueno cuál es la
probabilidad de sacar exactamente dos
águilas al hacer tres volados distintos
quiero que pensemos en el espacio
muestral cuáles son todos los resultados
que podría obtener pues podría ser que
los tres volados fueran águila digamos
águila águila águila o que el primero
fuera águila el segundo también pero el
tercero fuera sol o que fuera águila sol
águila o que fuera águila sol sol
también podría pasar que los tres fueran
sol sol sol sol
que fuera sol sol águila o sol águila
sol o sol águila águila y esos son todos
los resultados posibles tengo ocho de
ellos así que cuál es la probabilidad de
sacar exactamente
exactamente
dos águilas puede escribir a de águila
en tres volados en tres volados
pues la probabilidad es el número de
eventos favorables entre el número total
de eventos yo sé que aquí tengo ocho
eventos posibles así que este es el
número de eventos posibles número de
eventos
posibles
y de estos cuales son favorables cuales
satisfacen la condición de tener
exactamente dos águilas pues este tiene
tres así que no me sirve este si tiene
estas dos águilas de aquí exactamente
este tiene esta águila y esta águila así
que también me sirve este no tiene este
no tiene este no tiene y éste también
tiene exactamente dos águilas así que
tengo uno dos tres eventos que
satisfacen mi condición
estos tres son el número de eventos
favorables número de eventos en todos
favorables favorables es decir que
satisfacen mi condición en este caso de
tener exactamente dos águilas así que la
probabilidad de sacar exactamente dos
águilas en tres volados o la
caras en tres volados es de 3 entre 8